alors c'est une belle journée d'été
typique du québec on va faire du beau
avec messieurs du groupe b avec nos
capuchon ati et julien son chef dans
deux restaurants réputés de montréal et
dans la vie ils sont aussi cous réunis
en famille on part un peu c'est facile
et rapide
il nous propose 4 brochette inusité
patates douces poivre noix de grenoble
ou sirop d'érable maïs bêta jus de
pamplemousse assaisonnement cage à nana
fraise menthe et line mais d'abord une
brochette de palau alors on le vrai
juste avec le feu parce que j'ai pas
question de degré difficulté cette
technique peut se faire avec des huîtres
aux démos lusinga mal puis par la suite
on va juste les recouvrir un peu pour
faire une cuisson à vapeur un peu puis
dès que la coquillages sauve ses prêtres
pendant que les palourdes cuisent on
débute la cuisson des maïs en utilisant
des baguettes à sushis après on met de
l'huile des épices cajun fait de paprika
cumin celle d'oignons poudre d'ail et
des flocons de piment
alors le maïs est bien
et voyez le maïs a déjà changé de
couleur il est laid que l'on commencé à
gonfler alors on sait qu'elle est
presque prête
dès que le maïs a féminine oui comme
vous le voulez on va le faire un peu les
médecins auraient jusqu'à plus de
travail je suis ok on va finir avec mon
petit j le pauvre et surpeuplé mousse et
ça vous délaissez humaine en écoute les
épis scajola pamplemousse le world
series c'est différent c'est fun c'est
vrai fonctions les coquillages sont
maintenant prêts elle ouvre harper puis
à partir de là on peut lire on peut
venir force et puis savoir être seul on
peut tout simplement venir d'autres
chutes j'ai tâché puis par la suite on
va venir tout les aligner
on va revenir finir la cuisson sur dur
étonnant ce sont exactement son
sur un frère va l'embaucher à quai des
abricots palourdes et abricots parce que
ça on n'y pense pas mais les fruits sur
le barbecue ces délicieuses on peut se
permettre en fait de les traiter comme
une viande donc les faits a tempéré les
salles et un peu parce que le seul fait
sortir le jeu puis en fait ça ça leur
met ça les met vraiment en valeur alors
on finir la cuisson qui sous le bec en
brochettes
on va attendre cinq minutes d être
capable de le déguster
si vous avez un peu ça un peu plus
acidulée on peut acheter un peu de
livres ou du vinaigre ligne préférée
mais mensonges qu'ils trempaient très
serein mais c'est tout ce que je vous ai
je réussi alors appris qu après sa pâle
au mariage pas fait place aux patates
douces et poivrons patati patata tant
que quand on touche des bourines journée
le truc est de produire les patates une
vingtaine de minutes
on la robe de papier aluminium à
l'intérieur avant de le fermer un peu du
lot peu de sel puis on vient de mettre
sur le grill la chaleur bosse en
rondelles juste là les patates douces
faye a commenté les belles à l'intérieur
on la cuit plus tôt puis c'est encore ça
à chaud encore celle vinaigre de vin
blanc pour ajouter de l'acidité du miel
et de lui empli les joues cargo vers moi
j'aimais pas avant juste un tout petit
pas trop jamais encore avoir le psy
christian dupont
alors si cinq minutes au total d'exxon
on en attend grillades
je vais juste content c'est un fait les
manades nous à grenoble cuites au four
avec du sirop d'érable dachau voilà on
va y arriver avec nos pistes noires
dessus et on peut déguster
bonne idée annan a offert grillades pas
d'accord avec fraise hockey avec un peu
de menthe et des épices de la kbc du sel
du sucre qu'avec de toutes sortes de
légumes séchés surtout boyer m la fraise
qu'avec quand la fraise au québec et en
saison on montre que c'est bon on doit
s'amuser avec notre nourriture puis je
pense que justement avoir un dessert un
peu grillé ça amène plusieurs textures
puis darroman bouche et gaza s'est
beaucoup meilleur à 12h au mettre un
petit peu de lyme la somme au québec on
nous la donne
voyez comment une jupe sans leur bonne
éducation
quand même
ça c'est vraiment formidable ça nous
amène à ya aussi considérer le barbecue
commun pour faire autre chose que juste
la viande
oui ou du poisson noble et légumes les
fruits email
malheureusement le sourire
[Musique]